also hard hit is panama city florida
it's about fifty miles northeast of
Mexico Beach where rescuers are
searching for more victims Jericka
Duncan is in front of a Panama City pet
store that was destroyed by the
hurricane this Google Maps image shows
us what it looked like before the storm
hit drinka good morning good morning
almost unrecognizable but I can't stress
enough this is an image that you will
see throughout Panama City with debris
everywhere bent metal it's almost as if
some of these structures have been
through a blender now we got a
first-hand look from up above traveling
with the US Coast Guard yesterday their
mission continues to be to search and
rescue toppled trees and downed power
lines made some roads impassable the
only way to reach the stranded was from
the air we took a helicopter ride with
the Coast Guard team from Detroit and
the wreckage below was staggering here's
a marina off the nose here this is
pretty much as of last night the US
Coast Guard has rescued approximately 63
people and assisted nearly 300 on the
ground in Apalachicola we found people
clearing away the debris from four feet
of storm surge Eastpointe business owner
Michael Melander who wrote out the storm
says he's lucky to be alive we've been
blessed over here
the rest of me you know there's a lot of
lost lives I've heard a lot of people's
concern people like Jason Carpenter are
now without a home power and reliable
cell service we lent him our phone so he
could contact his family for the first
time since the storm hit the storm had
tore the roof off it knock trees down I
had to have somebody help me with it
somebody with a chainsaw I just wanted
to let you know that I was you know
alive hurricane Michael cut a
destructive path through Panama City
hundreds of utility workers are now here
ready to restore power but the debris in
this neighborhood stopped crews from
reaching a gas line that ruptured during
the height of the storm weary residents
literally held their breath while gas
company repairmen capped the leak we
don't have to breathe it anymore I mean
that was just one more hazard that we
didn't need we expect some of the big
box stores in this area to start opening
yesterday Sam's Club was open but the
line reportedly some people waiting as
long as five hours just to get supplies
now later today a local Outback will be
offering free lunch and Dana this is
that time an aftermath of a hurricane
like this where people will really be
relying on anyone who can lend a helping
hand because clearly by the looks of it
this community has a long road ahead
image is just absolutely stunning
Jericka and yes a long road ahead a lot
of people joining forces to work on that
Jericka Duncan in Panama City Florida
thank you